- On the screen I have these four shapes,
and I'll give you a quick story about
each one of these shapes very quickly.
And then I'll explain an
aspect of machine learning
behind these shapes.
The first shape is, very simply a line.
So, for example, imagine
depressingly somewhat,
if you're trying to buy
a house in the Bay Area,
and you make a plot of
the price of the house
versus the square footage.
You will see a linear relationship
and in machine learning this
is called a regression problem.
Where imagine that somebody said
I want you to predict the house price,
I'll give you the square footage,
you might draw a line
through the set of points
that you've collected.
And that might give you some sense
for how much you'll end
up paying for the house.
And obviously you'll decide
you can't pay for it.
But, nonetheless, that's the
process you'll go through.
So, I want to give you some insight
into how does this machine
learning process work?
What does regression do?
Regression assumes that
your data looks like
a line or a plane.
And then it tries to find the best
line or plane that looks like your data.
Okay, so keep that verbiage in mind.
Another common problem that
we solve in many different
contexts in business or in science,
is called clustering.
We're given a bunch of data
and you're trying to determine
are there self-similar parts of the data?
So for example if you've
collected data about
let's say, a lot of
patients who have diabetes,
Type II diabetes, let's say,
you might want to know, are
all Type II diabetes patients
similar or are there multiple types
of Type II diabetes patients.
So you might attempt to solve
it via clustering problem.
And the way clustering works,
is again very similar to regression,
in that you assume that
your data breaks up
into multiple pieces.
And then you try and find
the best decomposition
of your data into that
many number of pieces.
Right, so, similar to regression,
you assume a particular shape,
and then you try and look
for that shape in your data.
The third example is a loop.
Imagine that your are an economist
and for every year you figure out
the interest rate of the Fed
and the growth rate of the economy.
And these are your two
axes and you put a dot
for every year that you collect the data.
You will notice that the data evolves
in these cyclic patterns
where when the interest
rates are low, economies grow
and then eventually when the
economies have grown too much,
the interest rates are tightened
and the economy start to shrink again.
Again we are in Topsy
Turvy world these days,
so no bearing to real world,
these days, apparently.
But nonetheless, that's what
you would see in your data.
I'll come back to that
picture in a second.
Look at the fourth picture.
Imagine that you are, let's say,
flying from San Francisco to New York,
and you stick two sensors on the plane.
You measure the amount
of lift that the plane
is experiencing versus the drag
that the plane is experiencing.
And when you plot the
picture on the screen,
you'll see a picture
like this fourth picture
on the screen here.
Which is that, for the most of the flight
you will be in the middle
part of the region,
where lift and drag change a
little but not a whole lot.
But there's a few anomalous
things that happen
you take off at some point,
you land at some point,
and you might go into turbulence
and come back at some point,
and those are the three flares
that you see here, okay.
Now with this background,
I want to make two points.
The first point is that
the shape of the data
actually contains a lot
of information about it.
If you knew the shape of the data,
you wouldn't have to ask many
questions about it going in.
The second is we have great algorithms
called Regression and Clustering
that solve the first two problems,
but we don't have an algorithm called
loop detect or flare detect.
And in fact, the category of shapes
that you actually see
exhibited in real data sets
is so vast, that it's kind of pointless
to come up with a prototypical shape first
and then look for the shape in the data.
And so that is the motivation
behind using topology
to understand the shape of the data,
because the shape of
the data is meaningful.
Everybody with me this far?
Yeah?
All right then.
So, for people,
I'll go through this slide very quickly,
this if for people who
might be slightly more
technical in the machine learning space.
But I just wanted to give you a sense
of sort of how this interacts
with machine learning,
and how it's dependent
on machine learning.
So, what you see in this picture,
there are three datasets,
every row represents a dataset.
So the first dataset are
these two clasping points,
half the points are blue
and the other half are red.
The shape in the middle has
blue points at the middle
and then there's the circle that
of red points that envelops that.
And then the third shape
is basically two clusters,
red points here and blue points here.
Kind of like politics, I guess.
And what you see in
every column thereafter
is a particular machine learning algorithm
trying to discriminate
between the blue points
and the red points, okay.
So you see that decision surface
of these machine learning algorithms.
The exact names of these
algorithms aren't important,
so don't worry about those.
What's important here is
that you can see two things,
the first thing is that data has shape,
as you can see immediately
in this, for example.
The second thing you can also see is that
every algorithm also has a shape.
So for example, if you
look at the second column,
which is the first colored
sort of picture with the bands,
you will notice that no matter
what the shape of the data is,
the algorithm always has
this linear structure
where it will find a line
and then it will
discriminate away from it.
If you look at the second
from the last column,
you will see that this
algorithm has a shape,
which is that it wants to
discriminate data into boxes.
So it wants to find axis aligned boxes
that have various opacities.
And so the key realization here
is that data has shape
and algorithms also have shape.
The algorithms that we use
currently in machine learning.
So it is really important for us,
if you are going to hope to understand
what's going on in these algorithms
and how they make decisions,
it's really important for us to understand
how these two things are linked together.
How algorithms work together
with the shape of the data
and when will they make errors,
and what kind of errors with they make?
Everybody with me this far?
So just quick summary
and then I'll switch into examples
which will be a lot more fun.
Topological data analysis
basically is a formalization
using this old area of
math called topology
that allows us to study shape,
shape of data, shape of algorithms,
shape of decision surfaces.
For people who are slightly
more technical in the audience,
it allows us to merge together the results
of various other algorithms
in a coherent way
that you can learn from it together.
And the final point, the
most interesting point
is that it's a compressed representation,
it compresses the data.
And compression is really important
because when people
talk about big datasets,
how vast it is, big datasets are actually,
kind of useless.
You want datasets that
are as small as possible.
You want to eliminate complexity
that's meaningless, right?
So, if you go back to the thing
that I said about the map,
there's a lot of complexity in that map,
the exact shape of the
coast is kind of irrelevant.
So there are many, many details
in data that are irrelevant
and it's actually very
useful to understand
the essential complexity of the data.
So compression is a very key part
of all sorts of machine learning
and in particular,
topological data analysis
is kind of based on outputting
a compressed representation.
And it also happens to a visualize-able
which is very, very, very useful.